so speaking of uh young whippersnappers
uh roger penrose
yeah yeah so he kind of has a
you know idea that we there might be
some information
that travels from whatever the heck
happened before the big bang
yeah is that is gonna doubt it so
do you think it's possible to detect
something
like actually experimentally be able to
detect some
i don't know what it is radiation some
some sort yeah and the cosmic microwave
background radiation there may be ways
of doing that
but is it is it philosophically or
practically possible to detect signs
that this was before the big bang
or is it or is it what you said which is
like everything we observe will
as we currently understand will have to
be a creation of this particular
observable universe
yeah i mean you know if you it's very
difficult to answer right now because we
don't have a single
verified fully self-consistent
experimentally tested
quantum theory of gravity right and of
course the beginning of the universe
is a large amount of stuff in a very
small space yeah so you need both
quantum mechanics
and general relativity same thing if our
universe recollapses and then bounces
back to another big bang
you know there's also ideas there that
some of the information leaks through or
survives
i don't know that we can answer that
question right now because
we don't have a quantum theory of
gravity that
most physicists believe in and belief is
perhaps the wrong word
that most physicists trust because the
experimental evidence
favors it yeah right you know there are
various forms of string theory there's
quantum loop gravity there are various
ideas but
which if any will be the one that
survives the test of time and
more importantly within that the test of
experiment
and observation yeah so my own feeling
is
probably these things don't survive i
don't think we've seen any evidence in
the cosmic microwave background
radiation
of of information leaking through
similarly um
the one way or one of the few ways in
which we might test for the presence of
other universes
is if they were to collide with ours
that would leave
a pattern a temperature signature in the
cosmic microwave background radiation
some astrophysicists claim to have found
it but in my opinion it's not
statistically significant
to the level that would be necessary to
have such a
an amazing claim right you know it's
just a
five percent chance that the microwave
background had that distribution just
by chance five percent isn't very long
odds
if you're claiming that
instead that you're that you're finding
you know evidence from another
universe i mean it's like if the large
hadron collider people had claimed
after gathering enough data to show the
higgs particle
when there was a five percent chance it
could be
just a statistical fluctuation in their
data
no they they required five sigma five
standard deviations which is roughly
one chance in two million that this is a
statistical fluctuation of no physical
greater significance extraordinary
claims require extra there you go it all
boils down to that
and the greater your claim the greater
is the evidence that is needed
and the more evidence you need from
independent ways
of measuring or of coming to that
deduction
you